après quasiment huit ans de procédure la
chambre d'accusation de la cour d'appel
de dijon a donc rendu un arrêt de non
lieu en faveur de christine villemin
c'est l'épilogué d'un dossier qui a
donné une image très controversé disons
de la justice française christine
villemin n'est plus accusé de
l'assassinât de son fils lorsque la
justice aura été rendue dit elle ce
matin dans un communiqué commun avec son
mari nous dirons à la france entière
quel a été notre calvaire après
l'assassinât de grégory
c'est sa seule réaction ce matin
d'autres réactions à dijon cette fois
âne manga son avocat était au palais de
justice pas elle christine villemin n'a
pas voulu entendre les magistrats la
mettre hors de cause
non lieu total sans supplément
d'information non lieu après quatre mois
de délibéré huit ans dans quête de
contre-enquête huit ans à la justice
pour déclarer qu'il n'existe pas de
charges suffisantes contre christine
villemin ce qui est très important dans
cet arrêt c'est par ces motifs la cour
la cour la chambre d'accusation trois
magistrats du deuxième degré juridiction
sous la présidence de monsieur martin 10
et juge qu' en l'état il n'y a pas de
charge contre christine plaisent épouse
villemin d'avoir assassiné son fils
grégory gilbert vim
c'est un arrêt de réhabilitation totale
de madame film c'est un arrêt démontrant
l'erreur judiciaire qui pendant des
années s'est créé mais heureusement
aujourd'hui cette erreur judiciaire est
anéanti
huit ans après les faits le dossier
revient à la case départ la justice ne
sait toujours pas qui a tué grégory oui